[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
And welcome to "The
Developer Show."
This is your tl;dr.
Add immersive audio experiences
to your virtual reality apps
with spatial audio,
now available
in the Cardboard SDKs
for Unity and Android.
Learn how you can use Google
Sign in with your server,
in this post by
Laurence Moroney,
the third in a
series about using
Google Sign in on Android.
You can now generate
and distribute
promo codes to current and
new users on Google Play,
to drive engagement
with your app.
Use them to reward loyal
users, encourage app reviews,
and attract new customers.
There's a brand new set of
Android development patterns
coming soon.
The goal of the
series is to highlight
the fundamental components
and best practices that
can make the biggest
difference in your app.
Make sure to subscribe
to the channel
so you don't miss
a single episode.
Learn where your game players
get stuck, what virtual goods
they buy, or how
to tailor the game
for both casual and
hardcore players,
by using Google's Web
Scale Analytics services.
This post shows you how.
We're not just videos.
Check out all the
helpful written content
on the Google developer's
medium publication, written
by engineers for engineers.
That's you.
Enroll in Nanodegree
Plus, and Udacity
will guarantee you'll
get hired within six
months of graduating, or they'll
refund 100% of your tuition.
What are you waiting for?
It's time to start
that career today.
And you know what?
Sebastian Thrun and Peter
Lubbers are in the other room
right now, doing a Twitter
Q&A. Do you want to crash it?
I know I do.
HEATHER FAISON: So
right now, we're
having our first
#devtraining Twitter chat.
I let everyone know
that they can jump in.
They can ask questions.
So now I'm going to
put in question one.
Technology is a
global opportunity.
What does this mean for
potential developers?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
Sebastian, I actually
have a question for
you, around this,
because you started
Udacity as a passion,
to change how people learn.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yes.
And as an accident,
I should say.
It wasn't really a
plan, to start it.
We just put a class online that
collected 160,000 students.
And then I decided, wow,
that's quite amazing.
Like we had a soldier in
Afghanistan who, overnight,
tried to take
classes, or a mother
who was raising two
children and was
desperate about getting some
sort of self accomplishment.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And
seeing those people,
and comparing them to
my Stanford students,
my Stanford students don't
need me as much as some
of these people in the world.
MAARTEN: My name is Maarten.
FEBRIA: My name is Febria.
MARIO: I have always
wanted to do the degree,
but I could not afford
moving out of my home city.
PATRICK: I decided to change
paths and become a programmer.
MOYINOLUWA: I've
been learning online
for as long as I can remember.
HEATHER FAISON: OK.
Next question.
There's so much momentum
around @Tech right now.
Why is this movement
such a big deal?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: So I think,
as the Nanodegree agreement
matures, and as we're placing
more and more people in jobs,
I think students will
ask the question,
should I pay $300 a
month and get a job?
Or should I pay $3,000
a month and get no job?
So in Silicon
Valley, what really
matters is, what can you do?
So if you have a fantastic
portfolio, for example,
that you bid at
Udacity and Google,
they might be synonymous
with a good college degree.
In fact, I know
startup companies
who just pay zero attention
to the college and 100%
to the work you've
done in the past.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Is there anything
else that you want
to say to our developer
audience about Udacity
or your favorite
thing in the world?
What is your favorite
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I love you guys
in the developer community so
much.
You guys are forward looking.
You understand where
the future is going.
You are part of the
fastest growing technology
in the universe, ever,
which is called Android.
And keep it up.
Keep learning.
Stay humble and hungry.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thanks, Sebastian.
Well, that was fun.
Have a question for somebody
hanging out at the Googleplex?
Let us know in the comments or
with the hashtag #askdevshow.
Oh, and don't
forget to subscribe
for more of "The Developer
Show" every week.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is dev.life.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey,
Wayne, could you
push [INAUDIBLE] to the GitHub
repository, so I can test it?
WAYNE: Yeah.
Sure.
I'll take care of it.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
WAYNE: Network's down?
Cannot resolve host?
Oh, man, the network
cable's broken.
Now I've got to go
buy another cable.
OK, Google.
Get directions to the
nearest electronics store.
What?
Something went wrong?
No network?
Arrgh!
No battery now?
Oh, I don't need the map.
I'll be fine.
Oh!
Err!
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Wayne, did
you push those commits yet?
WAYNE: What does it
look like I'm doing?
[MUSIC PLAYING]